with concerns over low water levels in
the colorado river a coalition is asking
federal officials and congress to do
more to protect our water source
lake mead is at a record low level and
dropping
hector mejia live in our newsroom with
possible help moving forward
hector makers and conservationists
called for a moratorium on dam
and diversion projects along the
colorado river that they said
are wasteful the group met at hoover dam
and live streamed their demands earlier
this morning
they specifically called out the
proposed lake powell pipeline in utah
they said the project would hurt nevada
and the other five western states that
rely on the colorado river for water
the pipeline would transport billions of
gallons of water
underground from northern arizona to
southwest utah
the utah rivers council a non-profit
that promotes
sustainability says it would further
deplete the river
and jeopardize our water source the lake
powell pipeline
would deliver water to some of america's
most wasteful water users
in washington county utah
water officials from all six states have
been critical of the project
though utah is entitled to that water
under state agreements made a century
ago
water officials from those states
including nevada have said they're
willing to negotiation
we'll keep you updated reporting in our
newsroom hector mejia 8 news now